تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام لماذا لا يتعلم
طاغيه بغداد من طاغيه الشام يتساءل
ضيفنا الم يرى ما حصل لسوريا من خراب
ودمار وانهيار بسبب قيادتها الغاشمه التي
فضلت ذبح الشعب السوري على الاستجابه
لمطالبه اليس من الافضل لنور المالك ان
يلبي مطالب الشعب بدل تخريب العراقي
بالمجازر والحرب
الطائفيه ماذا طلب العراقيون سوى اخراج
حرائرهم من سجون المالك وايقاف عمليات
الاغتصاب بحق الرجال والنساء داخل سجون
الطاغيه هل هذا مطلب كبير الا يحق لسنه
العراق ان يصرخ في وجه عمليات التهميش
والقصاص او الاقصاء والاجتثاث
الطائفيه التي ينفذها المالك نيابه عن
ملال طهران راس الافعى يضيف ضيفنا الا
يواجه الشعبان السوري والعراقي ايران
الطائفيه الفيوني
بشكل مباشر الان هل يحق لنور المالكي الذي
تفاخر قبل فتره بانه شيعي اولا وعراقي
ثانيا ان يتهم السنه
بالطائف لكن في المقابل اليس هناك مؤامره
مفضوحه لاشعال العراق بنفس الطريقه التي
تم فيها اشعال
سوريا اليست الايادي الخارجيه واضحه
للعيان فيما يسمى بالربيع العراقي الم
يصبح او تصبح سوريا والعراق مسرحا لتسارع
القوى الاقليميه والدوليه لماذا لم ينتفض
سنه العراق الا بعد ان تخاصم الهاشمي
وعيساوي مع المالكي لماذا لم يشعروا
بالتهميش والاقصاء الا مؤخرا اليس من حق
رئيس وزراء العراق ان يحذر من تفتيت
البلاد على اسس طائفيه لماذا لا يتعلم
المتظاهرون في العراق من نظرائهم السوريين
اليس من الافضل لهم الدخول في وار مع
الحكومه المنتخبه بدل ابتزازها
بالاحتجاجات والاستعانه بقوى خارجيه اسئله
اطرحه على الهواء مباشره على الاعلامي
العراقي داوود البصري وعلى مدير المركز
العراقي للاعلام السيد عباس الموسوي نبدا
نقاش بعد
الفاصل
اوكي اهلا بكم مره اخرى مش مشاهدينا
الكرام نحن معكم على الهواء مباشره في
برنامج الاتجاه المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت
على موضوع هذه الحلقه هل تعتقد ان العراق
مقبل على ثوره عارمه صوت على صفحه الاتجاه
المعاكس
11484 شخصا
84.1 نعم 15.9 لا داوود البصري لو بدات
معك بهذه النتيجه ما الذي يجعل هذه
الاغلبيه 84 حوالي 85% يعتقدون ان العراق
ان المرحله المقبله من الربيع العربي في
العراق في العراق كيف ترد هذه النسبه
عاديه ومتوقعه خصوصا في ظل الاوضاع
المتفجره في العراق العراق يختزن البروق
والرعود العراق يعيش في ثوره حقيقيه علينا
ان نعرف بان الهجمه الهجمه الحكوميه او
الهجمه السلطويه ممثله في حزب الدعوه حزب
الدعوه المجرم حزب الدعوه الطائفي العميل
المعروف بعمالته والذي اسس لكل سنه
الارهاب في الشرق الاوسط والذي هو يعتبر
الرائد في الارهاب علينا ان نعلم وعلينا
ان نعود الى التاريخ اول من فجر الارهاب
الانتحاري في الشرق الاوسط ليس سلفيين
وليس جماعات القاعده ليس سلفيين وليس
جماعات القاعده وانما حزب الدوه بالذات
تبع الملكي يعني طبعا حزب الدعوه المقر
العام اللي يسمونه حاليا كان كان في ذلك
الوقت بالذات في 15 سبتمبر ايلول 1981
حينما اقدم حزب الدعوه على تفجير السفاره
العراقيه في ب الغربيه عن طريق انتحاري
يسمونه ابو مريم جنت المخابرات الايرانيه
اي سنه 81 1981 قبل ان يطلع بن لادن وقبل
ان يطلع الظواهر وقبل ان يطلع كل المجاميع
هذه والعم وهذه العمليه كانت باكوره
العمليات الانتحاريه وكانت بدايه وكانت
البدايه الحقيقيه لظهور حزب الله لانه كان
يعمل نور المالكي من ضمن الخلايا
الايرانيه السريه اللي اللي ضمن حركه ما
يسمى وقتها بالجهاد الاسلامي التي اسست ل
هذه العمليات بعد ذلك تطور الموقف
الارهابي نفذوا ارها عمليات ارهابيه
انتحاريه داخل العراق عام 82 ايضا عن طريق
حتى حتى يمنعون عقد قمه عد من حياز ببغداد
عام 82 وال نقلت ونقلوها بعدين دلهي
العمليه الثالثه والخطيره والتي نفذها حزب
الدعوه باصرار وبتنفيذ عراقي من حزب
الدعوه يدعى ومن اهل البصره يدعى رعد بفتن
عجيل كان ضد السفاره الامريكيه في الكويت
في
يوم الاثن 12/12
1983 هذه العمليه كانت انتحاريه بكل معنى
الكلمه عمليه هيئتها مخابرات الحرس الثوري
فرع الاحواز وبتنسيق لوجستي ومساعده ف
ايران ط طبعا فرع الاحوازي في المحتله في
ايران وبتنسيق لوجستي فاعل من المخابرات
السوريه هذه كانت قمه عمليه الارهاب ايضا
في الخليج العربي بعدين ما اكتفى بهذا
الارهاب وانما في عام 85 ايضا حاول حزب
الداو اغتيال امير الكويت الراحل الشيخ
جابر الاحمد 25 مايو
1985 بعدين لم تنتهي العمليه وانما خطف
حزب الدعوه والتنظيمات الاولى لحزب الله
عن طريق المقبور عماد المغنيه خطف طائره
الجابريه عام 88 وقبلها انب طائره كاظمه
طيب يعني ماذا تريد ان تقول من هذه
المقدمه حزب الدعوه حزب ارهابي قاتل اله
ايرانيه لتنفيد الارهاب في المنطقه وهذا
الحزب لا يمكن يعني هلا يعني بعد شوي راح
تقول انه كل التفجيرات في العراق وفي
سوريا وراها وراها بكل تاكيد ورا الخلا
لكن قبل ان قبل ان افصل في هذا الموضوع
علينا ان اسمحوا لي ان اذكر ف نقطه
تاريخيه مهمه اليوم هو يوم السابع من ايار
في مثل هذا اليوم قبل ثمانيه اعوام شن حزب
الشبيح النبي حسن نصر الله حملت على الشعب
اللبناني واستباح بيروت اذا تتذكرون في
مثل هذا اليوم 7 ايار مايو 2008 واعتقد
انه العمليات اللي قاعده تصير الان بتنسيق
من الثلاثي الشيطاني في المنطقه حسن نصر
الله نور المالكي والمجرم بشار الاسد
بقياده الشيطان ابو زور او الشيطان الاكبر
الولي الفقيه علي خامنئي طيب اذا طيب اذا
على ضوء هذا الكلام باختصار شديد انه كل
ما يحدث في العراق الان يبشر بثوره الثوره
قا ما ذكرته الثوره قادمه بالطريق بكل
تاكيد والشعب العراقي الان يعيش ارهاصات
حقيقيه لهذه الثوره ليس الموضوع موضوع
طائفي علينا ان اميز رجاء اسمعوا لي هي
النقطه الرئيسيه علينا ان نميز بين ما
يحصل في العراق من انتفاضه شعبيه عارمه ضد
النفوذ الهيمه الايرانيه وبين الطائفه
الشيعيه الطائفه الشيعيه في العراق بريئه
كل البراءه من كل ما يحصل من هذه الاعمال
الطائفه الشيعيه ضحيه مثلها مثل الطائفه
السنيه الان الطائفه الشيعيه محاصره
ومصادره من قبل الاحزاب الرجعيه والاحزاب
العميله اللي اسستها ايران واللي صرفت
عليها من من عام 80 من بدايه الثوره
الايرانيه 79 الى الان الشيعه بريئين مما
يحدث الشيعه ايضا ضحايا لذلك عندما نتكلم
نحن نتكلم عن احزاب السلطه نتكلم عن حزب
الدعوه الايراني عميل ونتكلم عن حزب
العصائب التاب
موضوعنا هذا مو موضوعنا
ضوع الثوره يشترك فيها سنه وشيعه ثوره
شعبيه
علا ما
حق بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اتصور المشروع
الموجود الان هو مشروع سايك سبيكو ا وهو
تقسيم المنطقه على اساس طائف ل تول العداء
اسرائيل البارحه دمشق بالطائرات والعربي
يتباركون ما تقاطعني تقاطعني ما تقاطعني
تقاطعني تقاطعني ما تقاطعني حيت ع دقائق
احي
دقاق
مقاك المشروع الان تحويل الصراع من
اسرائيل الى الشيعه والى ايران هذا
الموضوع الاساسي بالمنطقه فلذلك جئنا
وحولنا الموضوع انه هل هنالك ثوره موضوعنا
بالعراق هل الوضع في العراق ما يشبه الوضع
في سوريا صحيح من صاحب السيناريو واحد
والمخطط واحد والمحرض واحد ولكن الفرق ان
الشعب العراقي يختلف سوريا هنالك مجموعه
اقليات هنالك مجموعه تكفيريين العراق
هنالك عمليه سياسيه موجوده ولكن موجوده
وانتخابات اشكل عليك استاذ فيصل عندما
تقول الطاغيه نور المالكي الطاغي لو كان
طاغيه ما حصل بالانتخابات
33% لو كان طاغيه كما تقول انت 99% ياخذ
مجالس المحليه اخذ 33 يعني انه ليس طاغيه
وانما دخل في صناديق الانتخابات اعود الى
التظاهرات المطالب بكل مظاهرات العالم بكل
دول العالم من يريد ان يتظاهر يذهب ياخذ
اجازه صحيح في في الانبار وفي هذه
المظاهرات لا توجد اجازه ولا هدف
للتظاهرات
هدف للتظاهرات هاي ورقه وزعها النجيفي
مطالب المتظاهرين هاي وحده اجينا ردنا
نشوف اهدافهم المتظاهرين قالوا النجيفي ما
يمثلنا وما عندنا اجينا ردنا نقرا
التظاهرات من الصور اللي بها هاي الصور ش
رفعوا صوره صدام عزه الدوري هذه رفعوا
صوره بس التجرب صدام لابد الابدين ع صكم
بالتجربه 14 سنه
بالمظلوم ملوم
ج هظ لا لا
مو اغلبيه يا اخي ما نعيش هغ تلطم فيها
صدام الاقليات تعيش المظلوميه احنا ما
نعيش مظلوميه بالعراق احنا الاغلبيه كل
النتائج الانتخابات تشير انه احنا
الاغلبيه لذلك ما عندنا مظلوميه فلذلك
عندما جئنا الى التظاهرات نريد نعرف هاي
التظاهرات شو تريد اجت تشكلت لجنه سباعيه
وحققت مطالب المتظاهرين كويس حقق تطلقت
اعادت 200000 عسكري الى الى الخدمه يعني
موجوده مظالم عاد موجوده مظالم بس دا
داوود بدون مقاطعه عادت 20000 عادت 90000
رواتب تقاعد عادت المطالب الحقيقيه التي
تخص الحكومه العراقيه نفذت بالكامل اشكل
عليك بنقطه وما اسمح انا لاي واحد يحول
العراق ونساء العراق الى المتاجره حولت
نساء الشام الى المتاجره حولتهم الى نكاح
نكاح المجاهدين هذ نكاح المجاهدين عندكم
اكبر كذه اكبر كذبه عندما لم يجد اي
شي يا سيدي يا سيدي لا تقلي حرائر وما
حرائر
د بتسمحلي ب
اسك انتم متهمون في سجون الطاغيه وهذا ليس
كلامي كلام المعارضه العراقيه متهمون في
سجون الطاغيه باغتصاب الرجال قبل النساء
في العراق حتى الرجال عم تغتصبهم كذب ليس
كذب وهذه الناس
موجوده الا المتحده كذاب ولا امم متحده
كذاب من يقول هذا الكلام طيب كذاب من يقول
هذا الكلام داوود البصري كيف تر جيبي جيب
لي وثيقه جيب لي وحده جيب لي وحده تسمح
اول شيء من حيث المبدا ان تسمح النساء
العراق انشهر بهم بهي الطريقه اغتصاب رجال
اغتصاب نساء سيدي داود البصري لك الكلام ط
كذب من يقول هذا الكلام كل مطالب كل
المطالب العراقيه لبيت اوك ورائي ومنافق
من ينكر هذا الكلام الكلام الحقيقي يؤكده
اللجنه اللجنه اللي شكلتها الحكومه
العراقيه واللي كانت برئاسه الشهراني كانت
اللجنه تؤكد على وجود انتهاكات حقيقيه
انتهاكات في السجون انتهاكات في المعتقلات
انتهاكات على مستوى التعامل البشري
انتهاكات على مستوى الحقق الوطني لذك ل
طبعا انتهاكات طائفيه بكل تاكيد ل الحكومه
حكومه طائفيه حكومه محاصصه طائفيه منا
امير ومنكم امير لم تكن هناك انتخابات
حقيقيه
تهه حكه قائمه على اساس المحاصصه حزب
الدعوه في البرلمان ليس له س 16 عضو من
مجموعه 325 عضد ماذا يعني كيف يق الرئيس
اين
هذه
تحصص تحصص حكومه
طائفيه بالنسبه للانتهاكات التي حصلت حصلت
انتهاكات بسبب بسيط هو انه نور المالكي
اعتمد على الجماعات القديمه اعتمد على
اساطين القمع اعتمد على الضباط الذين
كانوا مستواهم معروف وممارساتهم السابقه
معروفه اتمد على اعاده اجهزه القمع
السابقه لكونها لكون اعضائها شيعه وليس
سنه حورب الضباط السابقون لكونهم سنه لكن
اي مجرم سابقا ارتكب انتهاكات وبقات بحق
العراقيين تم عتل السلطه وتم عتل المناصب
الامنيه لماذا لكون شيعي انا شخصيا اعرف
عناصر بعثيه مجرمه حقيقيه كانت في العراق
كانوا زملائي في الكليه كانوا مجرمين بكل
مع الكلمه عادوا الان بعد ان وضعوا على
وجههم هذه العلامه السوداء واص مسوين ساده
وعلماء ورجال دين حزب الفضيله وحزب الدعوه
وحزب ماعرف شنو وحزب البطيخ لكون احزاب
دينيه طائفيه غفرت لهم من ذنوبهم السابقه
واهلت لمرحله جديده بينما يعامل ابناء
العراق الحقيقيون الذين اسسوا الجيش
العراقي وساهموا في معارك العرب القوميه
وساهموا في حمايه الوطن العراقي يعاملون
معامله طائفيه و مبتذله من شخص ليس
له لا علاقه لا بالعسكريه ولا بالدفاع ولا
بالامن ولا بالاستراتيجيه وانما له علاقه
حقيقيه بالارهاب هذا هو الواقع اللجنه
العراقيه الحكوميه اللي شكلتها نفس
الحكومه الان علينا ان ماذا تسمي مزه
الحويجه ماذا تسمي مز الحويجه
ايامي لج برلمانيه عراقيه اليوم اصدرت
تقريرها وقالت
ان ان قوات مكافحه الارهاب هي
تح لجنه برلمانيه لجنه من بس دقيقه خليني
اسالك سؤال مثل ما سالت لو تكرم طيب
السؤال المطروح الان الكثيرون بالمناسبه
عندما اقول طاغيه هذا مش رايي مشان احطك
بالصوره او وضح للجمهور دقيقه لا لا لا بس
سيدي مشان احطك بالصوره انا زلمي محايد
انا اقول طاغيه بناء على كذا فما تاخذ مني
اوكي انا اسال اسئله واريد ان اسالك هذا
السؤال الكثير من الناس الان يتسائلون
لماذا لا يتعلم طاغيه بغداد من طاغيه
الشام طاغيه الشام ثار الشعب السوري لم
يرد الشعب السوري ال المستحيل اراد مطالب
بسيطه جدا فسلط عليه الجيش وانزل جيشه
ومخابراته وكل شيء وحتى فاروق الشرع نائب
نائب رئيس الجمهوريه قال بالحرف الواحد
نائب رئيس الجمهوريه قال ان الدوله
السوريه كانت
تتوسل رؤيه مسلح واحد في سوريا لمده سته
اشهر عم يدوروا على واحد مسلح مع هذا
وذبحوه طيب اخطات القياده السوريه وانظر
اين ذهبت سوريا الان يعني اصبحت مسرحا
للقاصي والداني بلد دمر خرب كل واح صار
اصبعه حاطه بسوريا ما ظل شيء انتم في
العراق ثار الشعب العراقي ماذا يريد الشعب
العراقي يريد يا اخي تبتعدوا عن التهميش
والاقصاء بحجه الاقصاء البعثيين والمحاربه
الارهاب قضيتوا على طائفه باكملها اللي هي
السنه السنه صاروا من الدرجه العاشره طيب
يا اخي عندكم مظلوميه بطبقها على هالناس
هذول يعني الى متى ب تتجر لي به مظلوميه
واللطم والخبط والدنيا والتجريح خلص تفضل
تفضل اول شيء هذه سمفونيه المظلوميه فونيه
السنه مهمشين بالعراق خليها على جنب انا
جاوبك لان نسبه السنه والاكراد بالعراق ها
باحسن حالات 30% الان عندك استفتاء عف
عند احصاء البطاقه التموينيه احصاء لحظه
لحظه حبيبي حبيبي هذا الاحص ويا
الاكراد حبيبي ه اطيك حساب رجا عيب الحوار
يكون علينا
ان هو سالني هو سالني هو سال حبيبي مجال
الان القائمه العراقيه ايش قد عدد كراسيها
بها 90
نائب الئ العراقيه
رس
مشكور احنا ناسس لفكره حتى نوصل لنتيجه
جبني على سؤالي للا ما عندنا تهميش يا
اخي اليس من الافضل الاستجابه لمطالب
المحتجين بدل اطلاق النار عليهم قتلتوا كم
200 واحد باليوم بالحوش ولا لا قتلتوا ولا
ما قتلتوا لا ما قتلنا مين قتلهم
قتل تسال وجاوب قاعد جاوب قاعد جاوب انا
ارجع لاساس موضوع التهميش وارجع لسؤالك
التهميش ها الان الوضع الحكومي ها 49 او
50 بال سنه واكراد و 50% شيعه هذا
التركيبه الموجوده الان بالدوله على مستوى
الانبار العزيزه
ها يا حبيبنا بها عش
وزراء عفوا عفوا على مستوى الانبار وزير
الدفاع نائب رئيس الوزراء وزير الثقافه
وزير كهرباء رئيس ديوان الرقابه الماليه
مدير البنك المركزي وقيادات من قيادات
الجيش العراقي هذول كلهم من الانبار
ومناصب حساسه في الدوله هم اللي قتلوا
اخوان ولا كان اتركني من القتل احنا قاعد
انت طرحت سؤال التهميش خليني اجاوبك على
التهميش وارجع لك على القتل تفضل طيب يلا
هذا ما هست زين نرجع للموضوع الثاني موضوع
اطلاق السراح قلنا حكينا به مطالب
المتظاهرين اجيبت وتم تنفيذ هذا الموضوع
بس بدي اسالك سؤال لصالحك لصالحك اذا اذا
هناك مؤامره على العراق شكك مؤامره على
العرب وع المسلمين انت عندك
شك طبعا طبعا طبعا اكو مؤامره ولذلك احنا
ماجرينا المؤامره اراد جر الجيش الع
العراقي الى الى ساحه الانبار وارادوا جر
الجيش العراقي الى الحويجه
وبتقرير رئيس
اللجنه عمار طعمه قال وهو دكتور قال ان
هنالك جثث جاءت الى الطب العدلي ووضعت مع
الشهداء في الحويجه وهي تم وفاتهم قبل
يومين اكو مشروع يا اخي يردون يكبرون
القضيه يسووها مجزره حتى الان يثيرون
المنطقه
كويس خليك وقف عندك داوود البصري لا انا
بدي اسالك الرجل يقول لك الرجل يقول لك
نعم كما حدث في سوريا يحدث الان في العراق
في سوريا هب الشعب مطالبا باصلاحات فقامت
القياده السوريه بتلبيه كل المطالب من
قوانين احزاب ومن قوانين كذا ومن قوانين
نفس الشيء يحدث في العراق طالبوا باصلاحات
في العراق كما يقول لك الرجل ولا لا
طالبوا باصلاحات لب تم تلب يا اخي دقيقه
لا مت سالتني عد
تجاوب يا استاذ يا استاذ عباس قاموا ب
طالبوا باصلاحات القياده العراقيه لبت كل
مطالب المتظاهرين هناك الان محاوله لتخريب
العراق ولاشعره عراقي مزيف لا اساس له على
ارض الواقع انبسط يا اساس شكرا يا عين
عليك تفضل السؤال منخ انتظر يعني انصافك
السؤال من يخرب العراق علينا ان نعلم بان
نوري المالكي في هذه الحكومه منذ عام 2006
ماذا قدم خلال هذه السنوات من خدمات ماذا
قدم ماذا قدم غير الدمار والخراب والحروب
والخليه ماذا قد اعطيك امثله الان في
الامطار الاخيره مثلا في محافظه البصره
الجنوب العراقي لقد غرقت مدن الجنوب
العراقي غ اين خطه التنميه اين خطه
الاصلاح اين التطوير اين المشاريع بعد بعد
تقريبا ثمان اوام من سلطه وين السلطه وين
مشاريع وين خدمات وين ه المليارات
الكهرباء العراق بحاجه الى 10 مليار دولار
حتى حتى يوفر احتياجات من الطاقه
الكهربائيه صرف 60 مليار او 50 مليار ما
اعرف الرقم بالضبط لكن رقم اكبر من الحاجه
المقرره ولم يحصل اي تغيير لس العراق في
ين الشهر الثاني وزير الطاقه لا اعلم اين
ذهبت هذه والله لابسين نظارات سود ما
تشوفون اولا ثانيا يتكلم عن جيش عراقي اي
جيش عراقي ما هو موجود الان عباره عن
مليشيات مليشيات طائفيه تمارس اللطم
والردح في ساعات في ساحات العرض العسكري
تسمي قوات مكافحه الارهاب جيش عراقي تسمي
من يطلق النار على ابناء شعبه جيش لا
يختلف الوضع في العراق عن الوضع في الشام
قوات الشبيحه السوريه وقوات المخابرات
السوريه يضربون على الاطفال بدرعه هي بدات
المشكله مطالب بسيطه الثوره السوريه
انطلقت من شعارات جدا بسيطه ما ان غيرك يا
الله واستمرت الثوره السوريه لو كان لو
كانت الاحزاب الشيعيه تمتلك ذره من
المصداقيه لوقفت مع الثوره السوريه لماذا
لانها ثوره حسينيه بكل معنى الكلمه ثوره
قامت من اجل يعني تريد ان تقول لي انه
الشعبان العراقي والسوري يواجهان راس
الافعى في ايران بكل تاكيد الشعبان الس
العراقي مصير قدر مشترك ح حكام حزب واحد
فاشي في السابق حكمهم حزب واحد فاشي اللي
هو حزب البعث الفرعي العراقي او العراقي
سوري اما الان يحكمهم الولي الفقيه من
خلال من خلال عملاء و وكلاء صغار يتكلم عن
الهجوم على الحويجه قبل ان يكون الهجوم
على الحويجه كان مدبره خطه مدبره حكوميه
عراقيه اطلق المالك التهديدات اطلق وصف
المعتصمين
بالانه انتهوا او ننه تنتهون ام تنهون
وبعدين اطلق عليهم الصفات القذره الطائفيه
النتانه وما الى ذلك بعدين تكلم كتابع
المالكي والذ والذيل مال خطه
م ا ورا قبل الاحداث بيومين يمكن تكلم
القزم والعميل الايراني والجنسيه
الايرانيه علي الاديب علي زندي الاديب
بنفس المعنى وهدد بعدين اجا المجرم
والقاتل الرن بعدين اج المجرم والقاتل
هادي العامري اللي هو عنده رتبه عميد
بالحرس الثوري الايراني وعميل ايراني
وقائد مليش الطائفي وزير النقل والمواصلات
اللي هو يفتش الطائرات الايرانيه شوف
المهزله بتوقف بسوريا بتوقف بسوريا واللي
هددها ويقول ما في اي شيء بلغهم طبعا
طائره نزلها رجاء اخوان فرغها من اي شي
حتى نفتش اذا سمحولنا ها معروفه الامور
فهذا حتى هذه العامل اللي هو وزير النقل
والمواصلات اللي هو وضعه في الحكومه ما
يسمح باطلاق التهديدات هدد المالكي يعتمد
على الواق واللواط بالاحزاب الاخرى
المالكي يعتمد على على مراكز قوه معروفه
بانتمائها وارتباطاتها بالنظام السوري
وبالنظام الايراني كبير مفاوضين دوله
الفافون او القانون اللي ما اجي باسمه
اللي ما اجيب اسمه معروف هو سمسار كبير
وعميل للمخابرات السوريه ورجل من رجال ابو
وائل اللواء محمد ناصف خير بيج نائب رئيس
الجمهوريه لشؤون او رئيس الوزراء لشؤون
المخابرات لا نائب رئيس جمهوريه المهم
وزراء فهؤلاء العناصر الساقطه اللاقطه
اعتمد على العصائب من هم العصائب عصائب
جماعه منشق عن التيار الصي تنظيم تنظيم
ايراني تابع للحرس الثوري اذا هنالك
مؤامره لقمع السنه ولقتل السنه ولفرض هذه
الاحزاب الطائفيه ولفرض الا اذا يعني تريد
ان تقول انه من حق العراقيين ان يثوروا
وسيث ثاروا وسيث وسيث الشيعه قبل السنه
هذه هي الحقيقه طيب كيف ترد سيدي سيد عباس
والله انا ارد انه الشيعه ثائرين والسنه
ثائرين الكل ثائرين ولكن ثائرين على مشروع
اصلاح مو مشروع انه هذا احمد العلواني
يوقف لا تقاطعني ما قاطعت ما قاطعت
ما بلا مقاطعه ر الدور للسيد عباس تفضل
سيدي احمد العلواني بنص المتظاهرين هو عضو
برلمان ويرفع السلاح خروج عن الدوله زين
اعود للسبب الاساسي
اللي التظاهرات وهاي اللي نقلتها قناه
الجزيره مو انا من عندي ها صارت هلا قناه
الجزيره صارت صادقه بما انه بتيجي على
خاطرك اما تردوها من العراق ما كانت صاد
طردناها لان دخلت اجهزه بدون موافقه
الحكومه العراقيه اجهزه
ارسال نعرف الموضوع نعرف الموضوع حرس
الثوري ش
يدخل صواريخ السوريه ها ها الكذبه هذ كذبه
بدون مقاطعه تفضل يا ريت تكمل نفس الفكره
بدون ما تروح عليها يلا شرف هو يروح يخوط
بكيفه انت فوت وين ما بدك بس الك الدور
يلا حبيبي التظاهرات انطلقت اول ما انطلقت
انطلقت باهداف
حقيقيه في مظلوميه في سجناء في اجتثاث
البعث ونبارك للاخوه بليبيا الان على
موضوع العزل السياسي راح يدخلون بنفس
المستنقع العراقي جميل جدا منيح اللي
اعترفت فيها كويس قرارنا
قرار بريم واحنا عالجناه مره ومرتين هذا
خليني بس وقفك دقيقه لانه هذه نقطه مهمه
وانت
قلتها دقيقه ب اس سيد عباس تعترفون الان
ان سياسه الاجتثاث والاقصاء والتهميش بس
خليني اكملك يا اخي خليني اكملك وجاوب
جاوب انتم انتم كان هدفكم الرئيسي اجتثاث
البعثيين واجتثاث كل من له علاقه بال
السابق بعد ع سنوات ماذا حققتم من هذه
السياسه الاقصائيه الاجتثاث سوى ان تبقى
الحكومه مزروب في المنطقه الخضراء بسبب
ماذا بسبب ماذا انا سعيد جدا او البعض
يقول بانكم الان تحذرون الليبيين مما
وقعتم فيه اذا كنتم مخطئين خلصت كنتم
مخطئين تفضل اول شيء قانون اجتثاث البعث
منذ اليوم الاول احنا طرحنا معاقبه وتجريم
حزب البعث جميل بعض القيادات هذا الثالوث
اللي مدمر للعراق طارق الهاشمي واسامه
النجيفي ورافع العيساوي هم هذا الثالوث
اللي عمل على ان يحاول عزل المظلومين وعزل
المحتاجين حتى يبقى لهم صوت انتخابي جميل
فلذلك ما زلنا نصر نحن مع قانون تجريم حزب
البعث وليس مع العوائل المسكينه ط بس
بسالك سؤال صغير ليش عم تجرم حزب البعث في
العراق وعم بتدفعوا المليارات لحزب البعث
في سوريا وهن نفس الشي وداك اتحداك اذا
تجيب وثيقه حده انه الع طيب ليش بتحلفي مع
بشار الاسد ما متحالفين يا اخي ما تفهمونا
انتم انتم عندكم نظر ولا الولي الفقيه ب
يمشي نفس ما ب الولي الفقيه
موزعنا زلمه الولي الفقير يمسك بكل مفاصل
الدوله العراقيه لا لا لا هذا غير صحيح
احنا ما ما عندنا امير مل احنا عندنا نظام
برلماني دستوري بالعراق لا يستطيع رئيس
البرلمان الان سميت الثالوث
السي نظامي انت سبيت اشرا
العرات
وعدين ارجعلك يا انه احنا نقول انه احنا
السياسه العراقيه استطاع السياسه العراقي
ان ي الامريكان وما يخلي لهم قاعده ها
مهمه جدا انت اللي طردت الامريكان يا
زلمه شي نكته يا زلمه انت طردت الامريكا
طبعا طبعا احنا طردناه يا حبيب قلبي وانا
اقوللك شلون الطرد الامريكي قصدك قصدك
الملكي طرد ها طبعا ماء ما شاء الله الش
لان في العراق رجال طبعا العراق كان خطين
يشتغل المقاومه السياسيه والمقاومه
العسكريه المقاوم السياسي استطاع ان يخرج
الامريكي دون ان يخلي لا سيليه ولا صينيه
اوكي بينما بطبيعه الاحتلال الامريكي من
يخرج لازم اكو قاعده امريكيه موجوده جميل
لذلك لذلك يجب ان
نحترم الدور السياسي للحكومه العراقيه
الدور وبعيدا عن الطائفيه يا اخوان والله
هذا مشروع سايك سبيكو وقاعد نتحول الى مكن
اسالك سؤال صغير وجاوبني عليه وروح لهناك
المالكي الذي يمسك بكل السلطات التنفيذيه
والتشريعيه والقضائيه دقيقه دقيقه بمعنى
احكام قبضته الطائفيه على وزارتي الدفاع
والداخليه واحتوائه للقضاء في ان واحد اين
هو الدستور الذي يتشدق به من كل هذا واين
هي الديمقراطيه المكفوله دستوريا حسب تفوه
المعنيين بما يسمى بالعمليه السياسيه
واحزاب السلطه العميله اليست هذه هي
الدكتاتوريه الطائفيه باقبح اشكالها
جاوبني انا كذاب يا اخي هذا بيحكي س هذا
بيحكي كذاب ق حبيبي اكو فصل سلطات بالعراق
واكو السلطه التنفيذيه كثير من القوانين
اجت ومررتها وما مشت بالبرلمان ليش اجت
بالقضاء القضاء ردها اكو فصل اكو سوء اداء
استاذ فيصل استاذ فيصل اكو ضعف بالقضاء
اكو ضعف بالسلطه التنفيذيه ضعف بالسلطه
التشريعيه دوله جديده اجت بعد دكتاتوريه
واحتلال لذلك ولكن من نجي نقول الان
المالكي دكتاتور انا اتصور هذه جريمه
يعاقب عليها من يدعي هذا ليش يدعي ليش لان
احنا قاعد ناسس انه بكره قد يجي نصنع
دكتاتور اخر يجي اياد علاوي والنفخه النفخ
الفح في غايه الاهميه داود البصري داود
البصري كيف ترد على الرجل يقول لك هناك
فصل ليك مهمه جدا النقطه هذ تابعت الحوار
وتابعت النقط اللي رد عليها تحديدا طبعا
ما اضحكني واثار دهشتي واثار حتى جميع
المراقبين وكل العالم يتحدث عن انه نور
المالكي وحزب نور المالكي واحزاب السلطه
الطائفيه التي ابعدت الامريكان هذه نكته
هي التي حرت العراق لان لولا غبار احذيه
الامريكان لما وصلت ه هذه الاحزاب الى
حدود العراق هذه حقيقه من اسقط النظام
صدام هل هي الثوره الشعبيه العراقيه امريك
هل هي الولايات المتحده قوات
الم خلف غبار الدبابات جابوا السبعه شياين
السبعه ضحكتوا عليهم لا امريكا لا تتصرف
بهذه الطريقه امريكا تصرب بناء على
استراتيجيات معلومه بناء على احداث الفوضه
الخلاقه بناء على هذا موضوعي ارجع لي يوم
قلت عن النجيفي وكذا والهاشمي وكذا تكلم
الاخ عن اشراف العراق واحرار العراق
وطاقات العراق الحقيقيه واتهمهم بما ليس
فيهم اتهمهم بالارهاب واتهمهم بالطائف
واتهمهم بنا ذلك السيد طارق الهاشمي انسان
بريء السلطه لفقت لهذه التهمه والدليل انه
السلطه عفت عن مجرم حقيقي معروف وكان يقبض
من القذافي وما اجيب اسمه حتى لا يسجل
علىق دعوه معينه عفت عنه وجابته واسست
قناه فضائيه وادانه القضاء العراقي وهو
معروف مجرم وسارق و ص ويقبض من المخابرات
السوريه ويقبض من المخابرات الليبيه ومع
ذلك فقد عفى عنه قضاء المالكي المسيس
والضعيف والغير موجود اصلا بينما يا اخي
مين هو مشعان الجبوري الذي كان احد ضيوف
برنامجك مجرم حقيقي استطاعت المخابرات
السوريه ان تتوسط له عن طريق عززه
الشاهبندر كبير مفاوضي نور المالكي
والسمسار السوري الاكبر استطاع ان يصدر
عفو عنه والان عاد الى بث
فضائيتين الحاليه وضد النظام الحالي وكان
يشتم الحكومه من على هذا المنبر ايضا هو
الان من العناصر
الوطنيه اقول انه اقول انه كل الاتهامات
مفبركه لكون طارق الهاشمي لكون النجيفي
لكونهم شخصيات محترمه اعتباريه لكونهم
يستطيعون ان يلفون الجماهير حولهم لفق لهم
تهم الارهاب العيساوي طيب بس البعض يقول
انه هذه الشخصيات كانت سمنا على عسل مع
المالكي حتى اختلفت مصالحها مع حتى لا
تضيع
مصالح الطبقات الاخرى حتى تضيع مصالح
العمليه السياسيه حتى لا تضيع حقوق السنه
كان من كان من الطبيعي ان ينظموا العمليه
السياسيه حتى يقودون سفيان العراق الى بر
الامان لكن اتضح ان ذلك خداع بسبب تغلغل
المخابرات الايرانيه وتغلغل ال وولي
الفقيه وتغلغل قوات فيلق القدس والاجنه
الايرانيه اصبحت هي المهنه على الساحه
والان يعني تريد ان تقول لي الثوره في
العراق الان ضد الولي الفقيه ضد النظام
الايراني وضد الفاشيه اليه الجيده كما في
سوريا لكن الاوضاع في العراق تختلف عن
الوضاح في سوريا العراقيون كعادتهم يصبرون
كثيرا لكنهم ان انفجروا لن يردع وستحدث
هذه الث والثوره في الطريق انتفاضه المدن
الشماليه والمدن الغربيه في العراق هي الي
على ذلك وحتى وحتى الشيعه في الجنوب
سيثرون بسبب اوضاعهم سيئه جدا رغم انه
الضغوط الايرانيه المكثفه عليهم رغم
الضغوط رغم انه الغالبيه الجاهله الان
مثلا ينكر اي دور عراقي في في سوريا ماذ
نسمي قوافل المنافقين الذين يشيعونه في
البصره وغير البصره دقيقه شو البصره شو
البصره سال سال سؤال محدد
لش اين د الحكومه العراقيه لماذا لا يسمون
هؤلاء ارهابيين اليسوا يقتلون الشعب
السوري لحظه لحظه انت لا تاخذ
السج بس بدك تجل لي اياها واحد امبارح كان
يدافع عن قبر الست زينب اه رجع على العراق
رجع على العراق عملوا له حفلات الحفلات
وبتقول لي ما لكم علاقه باللي صاير بسوريا
مش عم تقاتلوا في سوريا على اساس طائفي مع
النظام انت والايرانيين تفضل اجاب ارجع
للايرانيين الظاهر الايرانيين مشتريين
جريده الشرق الاوسط كيف ها هذا التقرير
ذاكرته جريده الشرق الاوسط على شغل رافع
العيساوي مع المجموعات بالسعوديه وقرت هذه
المحكمه لدعمهم للارهاب واستلام اموال
لذلك ها اخو الفق كير ل ها لان بها حقيقه
ما نرجع ل خص ق فلك
فك فلذلك طارق الهاشمي اعزه الله ها
الرئيس نائب رئيس جمهوريه سابقا والمجرم
حاليا
رجاء احترم الاشخاص المجرم هو النائب خضير
الخزاعي هذا هذا الارهابي الملا خضير هو
هذا المجرم الستور هذا العم الايران الاي
القانون العراق اي قانون هل هنالك قانون
في العراق هل هناك رئيس في العراق في
العراق لا رئيس وزراء لا رئيس جمهوريه لا
وزرا تسمي وزير الدفاع وزير وزير الدفاع
وزير الثقافه في نفس الوقت للقلم
والبندقيه فو واحده ماذا اختتم عن
البح بس دقيقه دقيقه تفضل تفضل تفضل لا لا
الك الوقت تفضل الك الوقت بدون مقاطعه
رجاء لذلك السيد طارق الهاشمي الان متهم
بالقضاء باجرام وهنالك مئات الشهود على
هذا اغتيال قضاه اغتيال شخصيات قتل كواتم
هذا الموضوع السيد النجيفي اعلى الله
مقامه رئيس البرلمان صاحب مشروع تقسيم
العراق والاقليم السني ها خلي خلنا اكمل
لا تقاطع تقا خليكم سي صاحب مشروع تقسيم
العراق
بايدن والمشروع الاقليم السني ذا ذهب الى
امريكا وصرح وقال ان السنه مهمشين ويجب ان
يكون اقليم عاد الى بريطانيا و عاد نفس
التصريح انا
اتصور سنه العراق يضربون النجيفي اذا سار
بهذا المشروع او الهاشمي بالقنادر لان لان
سنه العراق يرفضون ان يقسم العراق احنا
الرابط الوحيد القوي غير يعني الخصومات
الطائفيه بين شيعه العراق وسنه العراق
اصرارهم على وحده العراق فلذلك هاي
القيادات السنيه المفلسه تريد تقسيم
العراق يا عزيزي وهي وراء وراء وراء
الابتزاز وراء التحريض
الطط الان الشعار الشعار الموجود اقتلوهم
عبد الزهره يطلع فلان ما يجي هذا كلام غير
م كلام غير مغير
منضبطه عبد الملك السعدي لا يقول اللام
هذا كلام عبد الملك السعدي انا اقوللك
يقوللك حر سيارات الجيش وه هذا المليشات
المسلحه ولي يا اخي اكو جيش واكو دوله
يا بس خليني اكمل لك حتى نكون نكون نحكي
المصالحه ويدعو الى الهدو وسكينه ويدعو
صلاحنا خير بمجيئه ولكن عندما يدعو الى
قتل الجيش والشرطه في في هذه المدن
هذا اما موضوع ارجع سالفتك حبيبي هذا هذا
بيان العلامه السعدي احرقوا الاليات
الموجهه ضدكم ومن يقتل مدافعا هو شهيد
طبعا نفس جيش عراقي موجود بيا دوله
هذ
دوله كمل حبيبي اما اما العراق بالسيده
زينب اكو الاف وانت تدري كل الزين من ايام
علاقتك زينب سوريا وتروح وتشوف العراقيين
كانوا هناك الاف العراقيين فبقوا جزء من
عندهم العراق غير ملزم بارجاع بالقوه من
يريد ان يقاتل هذا موضوع ليس هناك يعني
البعض يربط بين ثوره سوريا وثوره العراق
الان هناك ثورتان متلازمتان ماكو ثوره وين
بالعراق ما عندنا ثوره وين الثوره وين
الثوره جميل جدا شنو اهداف الثوره حبيبي
بس انت الان من من من المقدمين البرامج
المعروفين والمشهورين اطيني اهداف الثوره
هل هو اهداف اسقاط الدستور كويس جدا نقطه
مهمه انا بدي اسالك داوود البصري وهذا
سؤال وجيه طبعا طيب لماذا انت تنكر في
الان ذاته اه هناك صراع اقليمي دولي على
المنطقه صراع على سوريا انظر الان كيف
يتلاعبون بسوريا الامريكان والروس الغرب
والشرق و يعني سوريا تحولت الى ضحيه شعبا
ووطنا ونظاما ونفس الشيء الان يحضر للعراق
يعني بدي اسالك سؤال تفضل بعض الاشخاص
الذين شاركوا في هذا البرنامج قبل اشهر
تحدث عن جيش حر عراقي قادم على الطريق مع
بالرغم انه لم يكن هناك لا ثوره ولا
احتجاجات ولا اي شيء اذا هناك شيء العراق
مستهدف اقليميا يتحدثون عن تركيا يتحدثون
عن دول عربيه تتامر على العراق كيف ترد
اولا انت تقصد العناصر اللي تحدثت حول هذا
الموضوع الجيش الحر الاستاذ هارون محمد
اذكر هذه المقابله واعتقد من خلال قراءه
تفاصيل الساحه والعمليات الدائره في
المنطقه ومن خلال قراءه الصوره العامه
للصراع في المنطقه يتب يتبع ان هنالك فعلا
محاوله لتشكيل جيش عراقي حر لكن لن تكون
العمليه بهذه السهوله وانما هنالك
انتفاضات وثورات نتحدث اجعلي عن انه هناك
مؤامره على العراق كما هناك مؤامره على
سوريا هنالك مؤامره يديرها الجانب
الايراني وتديرها الاطراف الايرانيه
والدليل هناك حشد طائفي يقود المالكي
وتقود ايران والدليل جيش المختار اذا
يتذكر الاخ جيش الم المختار اللي شكله
الارهابي واثق البطال زعيم ك هل قبض عليه
عمليات التجنيد والتعبئه مستمره في المدن
العراقيه وفي الجنوب ومن جيش المختار
هؤلاء يذهبون للدفاع عن مرقد السيده زينب
من جيش المختار هؤلاء باشراف الحكومه
العراقيه وبدعم الحكومه العراقيه وامام
عيون المخابرات العراقيه النعسانه او
النائمه هذه هي الحقيقه الجيش مختار اللي
يعتبر نفسه جيش رديف دفاع عن الطائفه
بينما هو اساسا جيش ايراني هدفه تقسيم
العراق ليس السنه من يقسم العراق وانما
الاحزاب الطائفيه الايرانيه هي التي تقسم
عراق وتريد اقامه اقليم شيعي جنوبي
م اسمح لي بالنظام الايراني ينطلق منها
الى
الكويت يعني هلك تريد ان تقول لي تريد ان
تقول لي هناك استقال ايراني للامساك
بتلابيب العراق وسوريا في ان واحد وان
الشعبين يوران ضد هذا اسحلي طيب يا اخي
هذا الكلام يعني ليس الثوره في سوريا
الثوره في سوريا تشكل بدايه النهايه
لايران لانه خط الدفاع الاول والاخير عن
طهران هو دمشق عندما يسقط نظام دمشق تنهار
كل الاحلام الامبراطوريه الصفين في
المنطقه ايران تملك مشروع جدا قوي وين في
جنوب العراق وفي الكويت علينا ان لا ننسى
الكويت الكويت هدف مركزي هنالك جماعات
صفويه لها وجود حتى داخل مجلس الامه وماك
داعي اقول هنالك نواب ميدون لمئ التقد في
الفكر الشيعي الشيعي ماذا يعني يعني
الطاعه الكامله المطلقه عندما يامره الفقه
ينفذ ولا ينفذ الحكومه الشرعيه من عن
الطلق لا اقول اسماء وانما حقيقه هنالك
مؤامره في البحرين هنالك شبكات تجسس
الايرانيه بالكويت وب السعوديه وفي
البحرين وفي كل مكان ولا حد يتحدث عنها
هنالك ما فعله الايرانيون في اليمن هنالك
المحاولات الايرانيه في غزو مصر يعني هو
قال الرجل بس الرجل قال انه هناك سايك
سبيكو جديده انت تقول هناك سايكسبيكو
بنكهه ايرانيه سبيكو ايرانيه اصليه لكن
اسمحلي بالنقطه حول اضرحه لو كان لو كان
الدفاع عن ضريح معين يمس اقليم معين
السيده زينب في ارض سوريه هذه مسله وكل من
يقات هناك يعتبر ارهابي لكن لماذا لايرس
اهل السنه مثلا فيالق لحرق حجر بن عدي نبش
من ق جماع غير
مسؤوله دقيقه بس اكمل فكرتي الفكره
الرئيسيه انه في كاشان هنالك قبر طبعا هذا
القبر خلي ب بموضوع العراق والثوره ما
نبعد كثير هذا القبر لابو لؤلا قاتل عمر
لماذا لا تشكل قوات العربيه او السنيه
قوات حتى تهدم ذاك الضريح اتحداك اك قبر
موجود فيش موجود تحد بكح براحتك موج هذا
ضمن التحريض باب شجاع الدين وادخل
الانترنت وتشوف دعنا من ه الموضوع الثوره
الان الثوره في سوريا هي بدايه الارهاص
الحقيقيه لانهيار النفوذ الايراني في
المنطقه لذلك يتكالب عليها العالم تتكالب
عليها حتى الدول الكبرى لانهم لا يعرفون
ما هو البديل نظام الاسد يشكل حاضنه
استراتيجيه وللدفاع عن اسرائيل نظام الاسد
يشكل اهداف للغرب اساسا يتعاون مع الغرب
من خلال 50 عام يعني يعني حتى الهجمه
الاسرائليه الاخيره هذه لا تعني اضعاف
الاسد وانما هي رساله موجهه لحزب الله
وجماعه ايران هذه اساسا بالعكس المتضرر
الاكبر من سقوط الاسد هي اسرائيل هذه
الحقيقه لكن سقوط الاسد سيؤدي بالتالي
وبالضرورة
نعود الى نقطه اخرى لماذا تنزلون الجيش ضد
المدنيين لماذا لا تتعلموا مما حصل في
سوريا اين هو الجيش السوري الان الجيش
السوري سنتين وهو يخوض اقوى واطول معركه
في تاريخه ضد الشعب شوف شو صار بحمات
الديار في سوريا بلد دمر ليش ما بتعلموا
مننا طيب لماذا لماذا لا ينزل الملك عن
عرش عاشت ايدك عن نصيحه تفضل اول شيء بسبب
حقد بعض العرب ام على على العراق كتاريخ
وعلى سوريا كتاريخ لذلك تشوف التحريض
الموجود عشر سنوات نصيح عمي مزاب لكم من
التكفيريين وقفوها لا تدز لنا اياها
للعراق ما حد سمع نظام السوري كان صدرهم
كلها اولاد المظفر النوابي مظفر النوابي
يعني دقيقه دقيقه وبنن سوريا انت ممثل
نوري الملك انا ممثل نوري الملك مش مثل
النور الملكي رئيس المكتبي لا مدير مكتب
مدير المركز العراقي سوريا
ل انا لحظه لحظه احنا ما نجامل اجت فتره
اردنا نوصل ويا سوريا للامم المتحده صحيح
او لا هذا
دليل لحظه يا اخوي اتركني من عقده ايران
انت
الحامله انه دليل على انه احنا تهمنا
مصلحه العراق الان عان الشعب العراقي من
الحصار والحرب والدمار لذلك منذ اليوم
الاول للازمه السوريه كان الموقف العراقي
انه يا عمي يا سوري تفاهموا ب بيناتكم لان
انتم بلد فقير راح تدخلون معارك وتهدم
الشام وتهدم حلب وراح ترجعون على
المساعدات الخليجيه اللي ما راح تستلمون
منها شيء لذلك موقف العراقي هو ليس دعم
للنظام وانما دعم او رد جميل للشعب السوري
على
على اعود للجيش فلذلك الارهاب عندما كل
يوم يفجر
بالعراق يقوللك يقول لك كل التفجيرات في
العراق وراها الايرانيين وب سوريا كل
تفجيرات في في شوارع دمشق ايران ولا لا
قلت شو
خصك تقرا ويليكس ويليكس سامع بها ولو
ولو بيعوا فلافل بشو
اسنا ذكرت بوكلكس من رجاع دور المخابرات
التركيه بارسال المتفجرات الى العراق
وتفجيرها في العراق وهذا موجود
بوكلان تذكرني سالفه وتريدني ما اجاوب عل
حبيبي الجيش موجود بالارض دفاع عن امن
العراقيين ولماذا يقتل 200 واحد قل 200
واحد لماذا حطوا راس الجيش براس العشائر
بالعراق انت بتعرف شو بصير فيكم اذا
حطيتوا راسكم براس العشائر العشائر انسحبت
العشائر انسحبت احنا اللي نراهن عليه
بالانبار ماكو ثوره لان الاغلبيه من عقلاء
الانبار انسحبوا لتظاهرات من كسر ظهر
القاعده منو الجيش والصحوات ل لذلك الجيش
العراقي في تلك المناطق اللي انقتل بال
الحويجه ها اثنين من بغداد وثلاثه من من
الفلوجه اللي يتكلم يقول لك يجب سحب الجيش
العراقي وهذا الجيش طائفي وهذا الجيش كل
عبد الزهره حبيبي الجيش متنوع والراهن على
وحده الجيش والجيش هو اللي يحمي كل ابناء
الشعب راع جدا نقطه مهمه خلينا ننهي بعنا
دقيقه واحده داوود البصري نعم اين يتجه
العراق رح ارجع لك رح ارجع لك بس دقيقه
اين يتجه العراق باختصار مشان ارجع للزلم
اين يتجه العراق الان على ضوء ما يحدث في
المنطقه وما يحدث داخل العراق خص لي
الموضوع مشان يرد الزلمه بكل تاكيد
بكلمتين او ثلاثه العراق يحتج الى الثوره
الشامله والى التغيير والى التغيير
والشيعه قبل السنه واقول ككلمه اخرى انه
انتصار الثوره السوريه قاب قوسين ادله
واقول كيف قاب قوسين ادنا ستنتصر السوريون
وسينتصر الاحرار مهلا دمشق تقاسمنا مراهقه
واليوم نقتسم الالام والرهق الثوره
السوريه في طريقه الانتصار سواء عن طريق
التدخل الدولي او او ع صيغه اخرى مثل ما
حصل تدخل بالعراق اسقط النظام البعثي
سيحصل في نهايه المطاف هذا التدخل وكل
الارهاصات واضحه ر العراق باختصار العراق
الان يعيش في طريق الثوره وهي بدايه
النهايه للطائفيين والعملاء كيف ترد انا
اقول من يريد ان ياخذ الحكم في العراق ا
عليه ان يذهب الى صناديق الانتخاب غير هذا
السيناريو بالعراق ما عندنا واقول كلمه
اخيره سوريا اذا لم تتم الصفقه او الاتفاق
بين النظام وبين المعارضه ستدمر دمشق وستد
مر المنطقه باجمعها انا اقول باخر بكلمه
واحده
لشكرك جزيل الشكر سيد عباس مشاهدي الكرام
لم يبقى لنا الا نشكر ضيفي السيد عباس
الموسوي مدير المركز العراقي للاعلام
والاعلامي العراقي داود
البصري نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى
ذلك الحين هاه فيصل القاسم يحيكم من
الدوحه الى اللقاء يعطيكم
العافيه
ه